[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
what's a Prof Maron why are we talking
about loud ATA again because it's
probably part of the end time message oh
and you haven't asked me how I am um
just before I get into trouble how are
you
I don't know I'm struggling with louded
here me too okay okay so that's how I am
as well so it was struggling yeah man
this is something that I think everybody
you either misunderstand it or you don't
want to apply it somewhere okay all
right now we've got a very funny
backdrop
here what's going on
here well
this is our walk to heaven and who has
to walk in front of us Jesus has to walk
in front of us but he's on the path yes
why are these people on the left and the
right why are they not straight behind
them that's exactly what's
happening we've got a message to bring
the world and the way to bring it is in
the middle path where Jesus Walks where
he brings Justice and mercy together
uhhuh and once we have Justice on the
one side and mercy on the other side
maybe that's our I I think that's a very
good portrayal of it still on you you
still think you're on the path because
you're following Jesus but you're on the
left so you're on the mercy side and
saying yeah you know what Jesus knows my
heart and you know certain descriptions
right there are certain descriptions
it's like in politics they don't say the
right and the left they said the far
right that's true the far left the far
left and then you have the left and then
you have the right and where's the
middle there is no middle there only
left or right or far left or far right
and hurricanes
too they they're not hurricanes anymore
now they are super storms and they're
not moving they're
barreling yes it's all the in the
description hyperbolic is that the word
that's right it is it's all in the
description and you're not a little bit
old and daughtery you're totally DED and
gone from this world so you know the
world is is very inclined to live in the
extremes yes and unfortunately it's
crept into the church as well so now
what is the lisian testimony it's for a
specific group yes it's for a specific
group and uh if applies to you then uh
you will look for a thousand excuses as
to why it doesn't apply to you it must
apply to the other guy and to him and if
it applies to me it's on my terms I want
to do it like this I don't think it's
like this okay but there's it's a
straight testimony all right so Barton
are you telling me that we must come up
to the testimony of the word and not
have the testimony of the word word come
down to our understanding exactly we
have to go up come a little higher okay
so I think we must pray pray because
this I think we must pray Heavenly
Father you've put so many gems in the
Bible and you've given us such straight
testimony but the way that we use it is
not always as to your liking so help us
to to know how to do it and help us to
deliberate on exactly what you meant for
us by it in Jesus name
amen
amen Martin humanity is very inclined to
say even if all I won't oh sounds like
Peter yes yes that sounds like Peter
right and we say if we' lived then we
wouldn't have oh for sure we not
realizing that we already
have the fact that Jesus died on the
cross for
sin classifies me as a sin and as a
crucifier yeah so there's no way I can
Sid step it and say not I yeah even if
there was no one else it would have been
me yeah it's my fault it's my fault it's
a it's a tough call no it it touches
human Pride oh for
sure and there's it started with Adam
and Eve so human pride is it's inside of
you even if you don't think so where did
Pride start well with Lucifer in Heaven
All right so is is pride
curable
yes yes yes it is but there's only one
recipe right unfortunately there's only
one
recipe and the recipe is death to self
yeah yeah now is everybody very cheerful
to accept that recipe no no rather death
to everyone else
right oh this is a this is such a tricky
subject because uh when you read the
testimony then you always want to say
fortunately that doesn't apply H we we
always want to exclude ourselves from
everything yes like for instance if I
come to think of it like the Pharisee
that prayed and said thank goodness I'm
not like the Publican yes
we never look at ourselves we always
want to see that somebody
else has to change but he left that
Temple self-justified yeah but totally
unjustified wow that's a very good
statement yeah yes self Justified but to
not in God's eyes yes but by comparison
it seemed seemed to him like that all
right so we must be careful of the left
and the rights we should be in the
middle but there's one other important
point you should have practiced the
latter without neglecting the former mhm
so what they were exalting in their
extremity in their Extreme Ways was not
necessarily wrong oh exactly that's
exactly true but they should have
practiced mercy and kindness and
gentleness and not bring in the
condemnation it's like the Pharisees
Jesus said do as they say not as they do
that's almost the same so it's not that
it's bad to have that testimony no it's
not bad to strive for Perfection no but
uh if you want to go to the opposite
extreme then it becomes your enemy
that's a problem and you become a
fanatic and a whatever terminology they
you see when Jesus goes into the city on
that path you can only follow if you're
behind him right behind him you're going
to bump into that sidewall over there
you're not going to get in if you are on
one of the sides of him you have to be
be behind yes and if both of them go in
together yeah you could have a collision
yeah uh
I I have a very naughty disposition
sometime yeah and I've told the story
before but I can tell it again I was at
the
University and at my University there
were some very militant
people and some very feministic
people and I was walking with a
colleague of
mine towards the Senate building we were
going to a
meeting and when we got to the door it
was a lady uh
colleague I steep back and let her go
first I got such an
earful she lambasted me from one side of
the other from being you know
patriarchal
chauvinistic how dare I because there
was no such thing as you know letting
the ladies go
first and it must have been a couple of
months later by chance I was again
walking with a colleague and we were
coming through the same door and I
thought to myself now what am I going to
do and I decided I'm walking next to her
I'll just carry on walking next to her
well the inevitable
happened we came to the door and
couldn't go in side by side and both of
us quand against the side now I was
expecting it but she wasn't
now what was she expecting me to let her
go first no because she had lambasted me
before so I remembered that but she
never said a word she just pushed her
way through and we carried on walking
and I and I wondered about this for
quite a while and said but you know this
this doesn't work there's no courtesy
there's nothing left anymore so that's
how weird you get and go the door
and that's when that will happen
whenever you take something and that
becomes your Norm of you you get too
hung up on something true well let's
have a look and see where this takes us
the
remnant well they say the remnant
started with Seth Right Through the Ages
till today to the end of time actually
it actually started with Adam right yes
with Adam actually already but then it
should have
gone probably through Abel yeah but Abel
was
murdered so what are the criteria to
qualify as the remnant have they always
been the same that's a good
question and the conditions that we find
in the Bible are keep the Commandments
and have the faith of Jesus or the
testimony of Jesus we find that in
Revelation 12:17 Revelation 1412
revelation
2214 and there's always a Remnant right
you did a a short chronology of the line
that Jesus was in and that Satan always
tried to get rid of that line well you
see the Redeemer had been
promised and obviously had been promised
through a particular succession
right and he would
come amongst his people so these must be
people that acknowledge Him yeah yeah
and uh the devil knew that and so when
Cain slew Abel he thought he'd gotten
rid of the
line but then he miscalculated with Seth
yeah I didn't get rid of him so he
finally managed to get virtually all of
Humanity on his side MH and God
permitted this to carry on until only
Noah was left yeah and his three
sons now if that's the line leading to
Christ if that line had come to an end
could the Messiah have come no no so how
long did God actually wait before he
destroyed the line that would refuse
salvation for all
Humanity well till the flood till the
flood and he wiped them all out and
people say that's a mean God what a mean
God I mean wiping out all of humanity
and keeping one family alive that's
disgusting right yeah and uh C was very
angry about this Plan of Salvation I
mean one little mistake and he was and
his parents were thrown out of the
Garden of Eden right and he wasn't going
to follow this kind of logic he had a he
had a problem with God's dealings with
humanity and and God waited until all of
humanity was virtually
apostate how great were Noah and his
sons no not very great Noah was walking
close to God
but was he faultless no did he get drunk
yes so he was perfect because the Bible
says he was perfect in his walk with God
but he wasn't sinless he wasn't sinless
all right so there was only one family
left if God hadn't intervened at that
moment all of humanity would have been
lost for all eternity because the only
way to be saved is through the line of
the Messiah but now if you take that
same line and you apply it to the
remnant it's exactly the same because
through Seth through Adam and Eve the
requirement to be the remnant never
changed yes it must you keep to the
Commandments and have the testimony of
Jesus so Noah was the remnant yes and
Seth was the REM Satan kept on gunning
for the Messianic line yes so if he saw
someone was following Christ who was
following God and he saw it whether it
was Gideon or whoever it was he would go
for their lineage yeah didn't he try and
kill all these sons all of it and you go
to the Kings and they kill all the sons
and they kill all the sons and they kill
all the sons and every time one escapes
he always misses Seth mhm he goes for
the others yeah and uh it must be hard
for him to decide because even
Samuel couldn't figure out who was the
the one through whom the line would go
right yeah he thought wow this firstborn
he looks he looks great so this must be
the one right no well then this one what
about this one no what about that one no
then it ends up with
David and that line so he must have been
exceedingly upset about the line of
David right and that's why also the
dragon was wro with a remnant of of her
seed all right now if you want to know
what he was Roth about there's a
definition there who keep the
Commandments and have the testimony of
Jesus those are the two criteria and he
hates them yeah so he's wroth he'll try
and Destroy them so finally he missed
the line yeah because he didn't think of
Mary no who was from the line
David uh least of all he thought about
Joseph who was also from the line but
wasn't the actual father yeah but God in
his Mercy sought to it that both of them
were from the line of David So in his
Panic what did he decide get rid of all
the all the babies babies all the male
babies just get rid of them why not the
female
babies because then the line wasn't
there the Messiah wouldn't come that way
so he being gunning for it all the time
so then he Jesus escaped with his
parents to Egypt came back when those
kings were no longer
ruling and uh there was trouble from the
beginning right yeah how many times did
they try and pick up stones and kill him
oh numerous times and finally they did
mhm but
unfortunately that was their death wor
exactly that really put the nail in the
coffin for them to to say so whoever
followed Jesus behind him was his Target
then exactly so the disciples did he gun
for them oh and he number one is to get
rid of them get rid of them or change
the mission of the Messiah if he could
only do that if you can change the
mission if he can get you to just step
off the path a little bit yes if he
could get you to covered that kingly
power that he
covered but uh to heck with the humility
stuff we don't want that right we are
too important for that if you could only
do that but he couldn't so now he has to
go for the remnant yeah whoever follows
behind that's the one he will go
for he's not so worried about the ones
on the left and the ones on the right no
no they were in in the church in those
days there were the Pharisees and there
were probably the Liberals as well for
sure yes so we have this this problem
here of this battle that takes
place in the following of Jesus yeah so
let's look at the ludan
testimony I saw that the testimony to
the Lans applied to God's people at the
present
time well it has to be because it's the
very last one yes there the last church
the lisian church is the last church
after that there's no church anymore and
the reason it has not accomplished a
greater work is because of the hardness
of their
hearts but God has given the message
time to do its work the heart must be
purified from sins which have so long
shut Jesus out the fearful message will
do its work all right Martin let's think
about that shut him
out in other words what is it that you
don't want from him well he's rules and
his humility exactly the both of so and
sometimes you accept the one and don't
accept the other all right so who Rebels
against Jesus self yes for sure self
yeah so the only thing that's keeping
him out is self because if you let him
in you have to surrender something
completely there's nothing of yourself
you can keep when you want to surrender
now is that in line with human thinking
no we've got human rights we've now had
a big
Sports series again you know you had the
European uh football matches going on
and you had the same thing in the South
Americas and it seems to me there has to
be a lot of distraction at the moment
yeah and then you have Wimbledon going
on MH and the Olympics is on its way I
think and the Olympics is on its way and
they're preparing for that and when you
see the pictures of those that either
scored a goal or those that just won a
match at
Wimbledon what do those people look like
do they say I'm so grateful for the
talents that God has given me do you
hear that anything but no you have these
mouths that are wide open that could
swallow a whole swarm of flies at the
same time you have the fist punching in
the air you have this uh I'm the
greatest I beat this guy into a pulp
yeah or they make a nasty comment
exactly like if somebody has to leave
because he just lost well enjoy the
flight home you know something like that
it's it's all human Pride isn't it
completely I mean if you even want to go
to the political sphere it's completely
self-absorbed all right if you take that
that debate between Biden and and um
Trump how much of I did this was in
there how much kindness towards the
other one zero zero
right let's not go there because the
point is human Pride stands in the way
of humility
absolutely and so human Pride shuts out
Jesus because that has to die because
pride is the very cause of the origin of
sin yeah yes selfishness and pride isn't
it wow yeah okay so that's the only
thing that shuts Jesus out and it's a
very very sad State of Affairs because
if you want to come back into harmony
with the principles of
heaven then you must open the door
mhm because he's knocking he's not going
to open it he's not going to he's not
going to force his way in he's not even
going to open the door to peep in and
say hello are you willing to let me in
you have to open the door you have to
say okay I'm willing to die yeah to this
selfish individual that I
am but as they failed to see the
powerful work accomplished in a short
time many lost the effect of the message
I saw that this message would not
accomplish its work in a few short
months it was designed to arouse the
people of God to discover to them their
backslidings and lead to zealous
repentance that they might be favored
with the presence of Jesus and be fitted
for the loud Cry of the third Angel all
right Martin why would you
backslide what does backsliding
mean I would I would like to say that
when you
backslide you are placing yourself back
into prominence and that which you held
to before you are making secondary
that's a very good Jesus was probably
the front and you were continuing and
then he started getting a little bit
less because there were other things
that and self started creeping in and
you could say the same with uh with
issues let's say sport yeah was sport
creeping in again and then once you take
part in that then you have to exalt
yourself it's just one of the symptoms
so backsliding can take place on a
spiritual
level can take place on a physical level
you can start indulging in those things
that you enjoyed in the past and oh it
is not so serious it's not so bad it's
only a little fruit
yeah and it's good to look at and it
tastes good
too all right so they were
backsliding and it would take time for
this message to
work why would it take
time because the the battle Yeah there's
a battle and your heart has to change
okay I saw that God would prove his
people patiently Jesus bears with them
and does not spew them out of his mouth
in a
moment he has such his longsuffering he
Longs suffering all right so only by
persistently saying I
won't will you eventually have to be
spew
out but he doesn't want to no no why not
because he died for you right so God
leads his people on step by step he
brings them up to different points which
are calculated to manifest what is in
the heart
some adure at one point but fall off at
the next at every Advanced point the
heart is tested and tried a little
closer if the professed people of God
find their hearts opposed to the
straight work of God it should convince
them that they have a work to do to
overcome or be spewed out of the mouth
of the Lord is that logical so if you
don't well if you don't like what God
says in his Bible
then exactly this will happen you have
to then you have to come in line with
him he's not going to get in line with
you all right so
Martin if Christ is
perfect and I am
imperfect then the only one that needs
to change is me yeah that's it is it is
it hard to realize that you are
imperfect
yes ex it is because it it fights
against your
Humanity okay but individuals are tested
and proved a length of time to see if
they will sacrifice their
idols and heed the counsel of the true
witness if they will not be purified
through obeying the truth and overcome
their selfishness their pride and evil
passions the angels of God have their
charge they are joined to their Idols
let them alone that's a Biblical voice
yeah ephrahim is joined to Idols let him
go there's nothing more that God can do
then that's a spewing out yes he's
actually letting you go yeah he's
actually not retributive he's actually
leaving you to your will and that is how
who God is yes he if you he's not
standing there oh you're going to and
with a with a rod no he's always
knocking yeah and he says that's your
choice okay so what are the idols that
you can be attached to oh money uh
entertainment food food drink yeah
anything anything that's
licentiousness media yeah movies tear
Jokers music
music but that's a lot of Idols yeah
anything that you put above God okay and
there's also a
generational uh equation in that you
know music might be more effective for
young people of keeping you out of the
Kingdom but I know of some adults who
won't let it go either oh for sure I
know of
evangelist who for the sake of Music
went back into the world mhm it's rather
sad huh that's exactly any
Idol for being able to let your fingers
go there you go you go because you can't
do that anymore so is the church
depriving you of a
talent yeah that's what what the um the
thinking is yes the thinking is the same
with sport yes oh you they're not
allowed to do anything on the Sabbath I
could have played at the national level
for example right now they depriving me
of that yes of your god-given talent
that's the one that they put on front of
you so God is you know he's a hard
Taskmaster isn't it bad how they use it
they say your god-given talent you you
have to use your god-given talent to do
what God does not want you to
do that's so true all right so basically
at the bottom of it all there's Pride
yeah that's it okay so you have to
choose between God and being elected to
to a national team pride has nothing to
do with it eh
no it has everything to do with it I
don't know how people can't understand
that all right but it's hard for people
to understand because I've been
indoctrinated so and they pass on to
their work leaving them with their evil
trays unsubdued to the control of evil
angels those who come up to every point
and stand every test and overcome be the
price what it may have heeded the
Council of the true witness and they
will be filled with a latter Reign for
translation now in this
world it seems as though you're
constantly having to give up yes give in
and give up I have to sacrifice
something but in terms of the world to
come isn't that you gain you gain you
gain the whole time so the
swap is like literally like filthy rags
for a rub of righteousness the problem
is our Focus yes the focus is here on
the Earthly things obviously it feels
like you're unjustly treated if you miss
out on these things but if your mindset
is in a different place you then you can
put it into perspective all right now
let's
say use sport again if you are a
superstar in
sport everybody loves you
if you are a superstar with
God the whole Heaven and the Angelic
host love you
yeah and uh what's the difference
between those two the one is idolatry
and the other one is what is acceptance
of humility
yeah because when you've given up
everything and you're humble the other
one is more important than you that
doesn't work in a boxing ring
[Laughter]
I imagine no you you eat first no you
eat first no you
eat doesn't work that way and how how
are people attached to their Idol for
example let's take a boxing ring how
many people have died in a boxing ring
numerous have they given up the sport no
and in fact now they've actually gone a
little bit worse now it's not only a
boxing now it's um MFC that uh fighting
without gloves and stuff like and
kickboxing right and then so that you
can't escape you put you in a cage yeah
yeah it's like the old Gladiators don't
they
realize what happened so have we gone
from bad to worse
right we don't learn the
lessons all right so they're joined to
Idols humanity is basically joined to
Idols here in this world in these last
days indiv individuals will show what
power affects their heart and controls
their actions if it is the power of
divine truth it will lead to good
works but if the evil angels control the
heart it will be seen in various ways
the fruit will be selfishness
covetousness pride and evil
passions could evil angels so twist the
truth that even particular aspects of
the truth become an idol yes that's
exactly well they that's their focus he
becomes such a health
reformer that Health reform becomes a
idol over and above the gospel 100%
would you then become judgmental yes
would you then become prideful because
look I've achieved this already
perfectly does that mean that you
shouldn't be a health reformer
no you have to be in the middle okay but
that's exactly what happens th and those
evil angels are constantly busy doing
this they're trying to use something
good like you just mentioned and almost
make it an idol as soon as it's good it
has to be pushed to an extreme yeah
that's how they work now Martin when I
say extreme does that mean you have
leeway to sin a little
no no no right this is very complicated
for some people to to understand and I
must admit I struggled with it for a
long long time as well what how do you
deal with it it comes to I think it
comes to an attitude all right on this
so be right with yourself but be
exceedingly careful how you tread on
those around you yes some lean upon an
old experience they had years ago but
when brought down to this heart
searching time when all should have a
daily experience they have nothing to
relate they seem to think a profession
of the truth will save them when those
sins which God hates or subdued God will
come in and S with you and you with him
all right so here's someone now that has
accepted the
truth and he loves the truth and he's
happy I found the truth but isn't the
truth supposed to work in the heart yes
it's supposed to change something
there's a transformation that has to
happen all right so truth in itself
doesn't save you no knowledge of it and
there and even if you have accepted it
intellectually if it doesn't change the
attitude and the Heart then it is
aserious truth exactly even though it is
truth must be applied okay you will then
draw Divine strength from
Jesus and you will grow up in him and be
able with holy Triumph to say blessed be
God who giveth us the victory through
our Lord Jesus Christ it would be the
more pleasing to the Lord if lukewarm
professors of religion had never named
his
name that's a real strong statement all
right so there's another statement where
she says that those within the church
are often better agents of Satan than
those without the
church because they like a decoy
yeah all
right and maybe we can just put it in
there is it important for us to realize
this at the time where we are living
okay so where's this going we can't just
carry on you know quoting one here after
the other where's this
going we are living in a time when the
final events are upon
us we
are loued see
yes let's just get this straight that's
it we are
loud therefore we need
introspection so when is the time to
have introspection 40 days after the
coming of Christ right no no right now
right now okay so this testimony applies
to us right now right right now I was
shown that some of the people of God
imitate the Fashions of the world and
are fast losing their peculiar holy
character which should distinguish them
as God's
people Fashions of the
world now it's not our place to
criticize everything it's to look at the
mindset
this testimony is it written for
everybody else or for you it's written
for me and that's how you should read it
okay are you happy if the church is
filled with youth
yes uh are you necessarily happy as to
how they come dressed to church not
always not always all right now we could
mention each one of those yeah but it's
just a symptom so if you're arrive with
your torn jeans because that's the
fashion and it's good enough for the
world so maybe it should be good enough
for God or am I going to be a little bit
different are you going to go with torn
jeans to a banquet with the queen I
don't think they're going to let you in
they probably won't let you in right or
audience with a
pope well with him probably it's can
still work
okay so always think about it in this
way are we going to be super judgmental
and this way or that way it's a very
fine line and it's very hard to
understand it is it's a
principle and again it just for me if
you apply to yourself and you don't
check everybody else then everybody
applies it to yourself bring the truth
rather than the Judgment all right bring
the truth and let the truth do the
cutting rather than your words doing the
cutting yeah all right so the
inhabitants of the Earth are growing
more and more corrupt and the line of
Distinction must be more plain between
them and the Israel of God or the curse
which falls upon worldlings will fall
upon God's professed
people so obviously the church must look
different to the world
they must look
different they must dress different they
must eat different they must believe
different they must be
dedicated and they must portray the
character of
Christ we see that right no not
necessarily right that's why it's called
lisia
okay I was directed to the following
scriptures said the angel
they are to instruct God's people 1
Timothy 2:9 and 10 in like manner also
that the women Adorn themselves in
modest apparel with
shamefacedness and
sobriety not with braded hair or gold or
pearls or costly array but which
becometh women professing godliness with
good works so you must be a pale
duck no that's how it will be
interpreted
that's the problem now only in contrast
to the world yes would it be a pale duck
yes now before we came
into this church many many years
ago if I had to think well what am I
going to get my wife for her birthday or
for whatever
occasion uh the paintbrushes and the
paint box were always a good goto that's
and
a nice glittery box as well yes so you
go and you pay a fortune
for this painters array you pack it in a
nice package and it is always very well
received now you get to the point where
it says no Take that away and replace it
with uh shamefacedness sobriety and not
with gold and Pearl and costly array and
paintbrushes
Etc and for the first time you actually
see what she looks
like is it a
shock if you are still worldly minded
yes all right but what if you make that
switch of mind then it becomes beautiful
and then the other becomes artificial
mhm and you think to yourself
but why do they look like that mhm it's
almost it's almost a shock the other way
around right it's true God gives you
Clarity of
sight all right and also the way in
which the eyes look Everything
Changes there is a there is a total
decorum change if the change is affected
yeah and that is beautiful that's that
is beautiful and so it takes a mind
shift and it takes a change of heart
it's not easy so let's be patient is
Jesus patient longsuffering for how many
thousands of years already okay so young
and old God is now testing you so it's
not only for the young but also for the
old you are
deciding your own Eternal Destiny your
pride your love to follow the fact
passions of the world your Vain and
empty
conversation your selfishness are all
put on the scale and the weight of evil
is fearfully against you you are poor
and miserable and
blind and naked what this is serious
introspection you know the pride has to
be set
aside so wasn't
if we are the people that are on the
verge of going through to the
kingdom then all of these things of the
world must be counted as not exactly
nothing of the world must be holding you
back on anything that God wants you to
do all right
now once you do this do you feel
deprived at first if your mindset is not
right yes you do but if your mindset
comes right are you then deprived or are
you enriched much more enriched than
ever you were before okay it's very
difficult for people to understand that
it is especially if you're standing on
the other side yes if you if you hear
this and you are new to this whole walk
with God this is it's not it doesn't
work not easy to swallow many I saw were
flattering themselves that they were
good Christians who have not a single
ray of light from Jesus
good Christians not having a single ray
of light from Jesus because there's no
difference between them and the world
yeah they know not what it is to be
renewed by the grace of God they have no
living experience for themselves in the
things of God and I saw that the Lord
was wetting his sword in heaven to cut
them down oh that every cold lukewarm
Professor could realize the clean work
that God is about to make amongst his
professed people
people Martin are we being judgmental by
putting these quotes up the contrary and
that's what this whole lecture is about
or this whole
discussion this is the testimony to the
lisian church which we are like you've
mentioned before yes how we deal with
this will determine on which side we are
where we are so it's it's very important
that we don't divide this discussion
into them and
us 100% this is It's never them it's
always us us like Daniel when he prayed
and he asked for forgiveness he didn't
say they he said he means included in
that whole pray have sin all right
Martin let's look at the statements for
young Sabbath Keepers I saw that the
young do not take the burden nor feel
the responsibility of the cause of God
is it because God has excused them oh no
I I saw that they excused themselves
they are eased and others are burdened
they do not realize that they are not
their
own now when you
take uh the way in which God worked in
the past did he bypass the young or did
he Target them he targeted them his
disciples how old were they young young
young I mean 17 years old yeah they were
young right even if you go back uh
Daniel Joseph all of these that stood
for God and then you come to the
pioneers of this of our church but they
were they were minorities right always
The Remnant always
minorities so this is not a blanket
accusation against the young this is a
state of mind that is prevalent amongst
the young yes and it's a wake up call so
if this talks to you change so many of
the young I saw have not the spirit of
Jesus the love of God is not in their
hearts therefore all the natural
besetment hold the victory instead of
the spirit of God and
salvation it is the lack of religion
lack of holy living that makes the young
backward all right lack of
religion that's not understanding the
issues yes not the lack of knowledge of
religion and lack of religion app living
what you know yes a lack of the holy
living that makes the young backwards a
holy living means living in the will of
God that means your language is cleaned
yeah that means what goes into the mouth
is
clean that means what comes out of the
mouth is
clean that means your decorum is clean
and if it's not then you go backwards
their life condemns them they know that
they do not live as Christians should
therefore they have not confidence
towards God or before the church now
when you and I well not me I wasn't
living in Rebellion I was Rebellion yeah
CU I didn't know the truth M but if you
know the truth like my son for example
he knew the truth but he chose a life of
rebellion
yeah and then when he had to come back
or when the call came to him come
back it was very hard for him and in the
beginning it was a burden he knew he had
to do it but he's his system rebelled
against it exactly until that which you
do becomes better than that which you
did yes and God takes hold of you and
even what you like like you mentioned
mentioned before what I used to like I
now dislike and what I used to dislike I
now right so I want to say to the youth
you must get to the point where that
which you love you hate yeah and that
which you ha it you now love Yeah in the
world the world lead it's it's it's it's
yeah mindset changed what did you say
hard cognitive dissonance all right and
and does peer pressure prevent you from
doing it oh completely because that
where Satan works best and this can also
be applied to people that are new to the
truth yes so young Sabbath keepers are
young of age and also people that are
young in getting the truths of the Bible
yeah Martin isn't it a lot easier to
speak about Doctrine and truth and error
and things and what's happening in the
world than speaking about these things
it's much easier much easier right yes
because this has to work on our hearts
as well is so how little do the young
suffer or deny self for their religion
to sacrifice is scarcely thought of
amongst them they they entirely fail of
imitating the pattern in this respect I
saw that this was the language of their
lives self must be gratified Pride must
be indulged they forget the Man of
Sorrows who was acquainted with
grief it's a hard choice because
why do you want to do this why do you
want to walk the path of Sorrows if you
can walk the path of
exaltation and why you always have to be
so um different
yes now why was he a Man of Sorrows he
was a Man of Sorrows because he knew
what was
right but he also knew that nobody
wanted
him and that made him sorrowful because
he also knew that if you didn't want it
you didn't qualify for heaven that's he
knew that's why he was sorrowful okay so
in heaven where everybody does the will
of God is he a Man of Sorrows no he's a
man of
Jubilation so is it possible to change
from a Man of Sorrows to a man of
Jubilation yes and you can do it here as
well I want these to be where I am also
yeah I want them there and when they are
there he looks at the travail and he
says it was worth it it was worth it and
we will say heaven was cheap enough
heaven was cheap enough so
Martin uh if you have this
concept of long-faced
Christianity a life of toil and misery
then you will choose the world that's
what happened to Martin Luther because
when he was a monk that is the life you
have it's misery and you you you can't
be saved and when he discovered but he
wanted to go to heaven so he chose to
rather go through the suffering as a
exactly but then he discovered the Man
of
Sorrows and his his whole life changed
okay so we have to Define why he is a
Man of Sorrows I think we've done it
yeah he is a Man of Sorrows because he
knows the consequences of sin and he
knows the choices that people make that
make him sorrowful it's like a parent
that sees child going the wrong way and
he becomes
sorrowful and when he sees him going the
right way he becomes joyful exactly so
in heaven the man of Joy will be Christ
yes and those that have followed him
will be the children of
Joy so don't look at the way in which
the world is running now yeah keep your
eyes focused on the
future the sufferings of Jesus in
Gethsemane he sweating as it were great
drops of blood in the garden the planted
Crown of Thorns that pierced his holy
brow do not move them they have become
been numbed their sensibilities are
blunted they have lost all sense of the
great sacrifice for them they don't want
to go there no they don't want to go
there and least of all do they want to
follow there want a life of ease
according to the world yes because
otherwise you've always got somebody why
are you like this Why didn't it like you
mentioned before you it seems like
you're always deprived of everything in
life yes everything that's fun is gone
those only who have partaken of the
suffering of the Son of God and have
come up through the Great Tribulation
have washed their robes and made them
whiten the blood of the Lamb can enjoy
the Indescribable glory and unsurpassed
beauty of Heaven is there something
positive on the other side yes something
unsurpassed now there's a song which
says I'm a pilgrim
mhm
right and uh you're a pil in this this
sad world let's let's say uh you have a
nuclear
apocalypse and you're walking through
this nuclear apocalypse there's a lot of
sadness on the left and on the right and
people bleeding and people dying of
radiation sickness and basically that's
the state we are in yeah the world is
the world is in that
state and if this is your world then
it's a rather sad place place to be cuz
it's not going to improve it's going to
go from bad to worse but if your focus
is on the unsurpassed beauty of Heaven
not only physically but character-wise
then all of those things which you
counted of such great value are actually
meaningless
but speaking those words for somebody
that hasn't realized this yet that's it
doesn't you have to get to that that
words get meaning to you okay now let's
take a little round object about this
size and a
net and your ability of your foot to
kick this little round object into that
net that is the whole tenor of your
life on a scale of 1 to 10 how important
is
that compared to what is
available zero zero right but people
make it their entire life exactly they
live it they eat it they drink it they
spend all their money on it and what
does it bring you in the end that you
were able with your foot to take the
round object and put it in a net maybe
you only get a little certificate or a
small Idol that's acknowledges that you
were good but that's there's a distant
memory of you after a while while now
imagine the whole universe being open to
you you're being able to go anywhere in
the universe study the depth of the
universe understand how everything is
put together everything that man strives
for never
achieves where we live on theories don't
we yeah and the next generation will Pro
prove your theory wrong yeah so you
actually lived a lie is it worth it to
lose eternal life for for the sake of a
lie let's take Evolution yeah are
evolutionists willing to forgo eternal
life for the sake of a lie no oh yes
they are yes yeah yes they are right yes
okay so M we don't have a
perception of Heaven no because
otherwise you that will be where your
focus is okay so M if we don't have a
per C of Heaven would we want to prepare
for it no that brings us to the next
point the want of this necessary
preparation will shut out the greatest
portion of young professors for they
will not labor earnestly and zealously
enough to obtain that rest that remains
for the people of God I saw that Jesus
was now giving them opportunity to
confess to repent in deep humility and
purify their lives by obeying and living
the truth
I saw that now was the time for wrongs
to be writed sins to be confessed or
appear before the sinner in the day of
God's wroth so your sins will either
catch up with you or you will be able to
get rid of them by following the
prescribed
course in terms of what the world offers
you not a choice that everybody is
willing to make and when it says young
professors this doesn't have to be a
young person no can be a new convert
yeah Jacob likee wrestle in prayer
agonize Jesus in the garden sweat great
drops of blood you must make an effort
do not leave your closet until you feel
strong in God then watch and just as
long as you watch and pray you can keep
these Evil besetment under and the grace
of God can and will appear in you they
will call you a nerd yeah or a Jesus
Freak or something you know okay I saw
that the Christian should not set too
high a value nor depend too much upon a
happy flight of feeling these feelings
are not always true I saw that it should
be the study of every Christian to serve
God from principle and not be ruled by
feeling is Satan a master at creating
religious emotion oh for sure I think
he's the master of
entertainment
ahuh so when you go to church are you
going there for a flight of feeling are
you going there to be entertained are
you going there for a
rush or are you going there to spend
time with God and allowing the Holy
Spirit to work on you you see that's
where Satan is a very good deceiver
because the world is
so feeling
based he wants young people or most
people want to feel the same when they
get into church okay and
obviously you have to put it in
perspective now is that what God wants
because otherwise God's
boring until you get the your your
mindset right on that portion okay so
God is actually everything but boring
yeah so the problem is really the
mindset that's
it I was shown that if the chrisan lives
a humble self-sacrificing life to God
peace and joy in the Lord will be the
result but the greatest happiness
experienced will be in doing others good
in making others happy such happiness
will be lasting it's the opposite of the
world's thinking yeah completely so even
the philanthropist of the world today
are showing this great generosity
actually to exalt themselves themselves
so as as soon as you move this Shi do
the shift from yourself to somebody else
then you will be truly happy but that's
opposite of what the world tells you you
must believe in yourself you must do
your best you you must follow your heart
follow your heart that it's only you you
you the whole time but the heart is
desperately
wicked Above All Things
I saw that some would have to walk the
straight path alone their Companions and
children will not walk the self-denying
pathway with them that makes it even
harder yeah patience and forbearance
should characterize the lives of those
lone pilgrims following the
example of their blessed Master he
eventually walked totally alone yeah
they all forsook him doesn't the Bible
say all forsook him
they'll have many trials to endure but
they have a hope that makes the soul
strong the only
way that you can survive this kind of
situation let's say you're in a marriage
relationship where the one just
absolutely refuses to follow this path
and you follow it which means that you
have zero Joy yeah the only way you can
survive it is if you provide joy for
others perfect perfectly put yeah only
way you can survive that's the only way
so if you see the joy in other people's
faces that accept it it can help you get
over the sadness of those that don't
accept exactly they're very well put but
if your companions and your children
will not come if you cannot win them to
yield to the claims of Truth make their
lives here as pleasant as possible for
all they will ever enjoy will be this
poor world but let not your duties them
interfere with your duty towards God so
the advice that we have here is put your
heart and soul into the work yes see the
results of your work from the outside
and you will receive a joy that
surpasses all understanding so if your
focus is on the right place you can bear
all these other things yeah yes and the
way that you should bear it is still in
a Godly manner yes and you must retain
your cheerfulness yes and your um
compassion and pray that your
cheerfulness will be contagious to those
that oppose you yeah even though they
probably will get angry if you are
cheerful if they are trying their best
to be miserable the more you do God's
will the more agitation you will get
from the world right my that brings us
to another point if you want to be happy
in the loudan
church then put your shoulder to the
wheel yes do God's work do the work of
the ministry and don't fight all of
these things within because you will not
succeed in changing them no don't go and
take this testimony that we've just read
and Bash people over the head with it no
you can't no it's an individual work for
themselves to work out
correct so again to story you're
standing on the wall of
Zion with your face looking at the world
out there looking for the enemy to come
and looking for those that you can
possibly reach with a
message that brings Joy yeah exactly
facing the church and trying to fix the
church brings misery for sure as we near
the Judgment all will manifest their
true character and it will be made plain
to what company they belong the Civ is
going let us not say stay thy hand oh
God we know not the heart of man The
Church Must Be purged and will be so
there will be a shaking yes now if we go
to the litan church in the beginning the
Pioneers didn't think that the message
applied to
them they thought it applied to the
nominal churches that weren't accepting
the truth the Commandments of God and
the testimony of Jesus
right and then they were thoroughly
shocked when they realized that it
applied to them yes then this lisian
testimony came and said no you guys
better and some of them and some of them
said but you know here are there that
keep the Commandments we are the ones
that are keeping the Commandments
therefore we are righteous with God we
cannot be louded yeah and then came the
message of righteousness by faith yes
1888 and when you accept the message of
righteousness by faith then where are
your
Works secondary secondary yeah so
everything that you boasted about
yourself becomes meaningless exactly
does that mean you mustn't keep the
Commandments no they were too much on
that side
understand come a little bit come back
into the middle all right so the entire
church just about
split
including presidents and leaders within
the church and they fought against this
message tooth and nail because just
think about it your righteousness is all
of a sudden removed you have none that
which you thought okay this made that I
am okay yes it's gone it's carpet pulled
right from under you the rug all right
so all your works are now filthy rags
that must have been quite a blow to them
mhm and it took some of them a long time
and some of them never got there to
accept this but unfortunately as in most
of history history has a tendency to
repeat itself and it will repeat itself
in our time so M when you are
purged it is because of
self-righteousness yes it's a
self-righteousness has that has to be
purged out of you either I'm good enough
because I keep the Commandments mhm or
God will accept me like I am yeah one of
the two you're either on that one or on
the other
side so in the spring of
1857 I accompanied my husband to the on
a tour of the
East his principal business was to
purchase the power press we held
conferences on our way to Boston and on
our return this was a discouraging tour
the testimony to the Lan church was
generally received but some in the East
were making bad use of it instead of
applying it to their own Hearts so as to
be benefited by it themselves they were
using the testimony to oppress
others so this that's not a test not the
case anymore right no that's you see
so like we mentioned before this
testimony that we just read was for
every individual in the church in our
church in us it's us yes but then what
happens exactly the same happens you use
it as a bashing tool a few taught that
the Brethren must sell all out before
they could be free while some others
dwelt much upon dress carrying the
subject to an extreme and with a few
others there was a narrowing of the work
of the third message and following of
Impressions and casting fear upon the
conscientious these things have had a
blighting influence and have caused us
to lay down our testimony on the subject
almost entirely so if it causes so much
turmoil don't speak about it and that's
what happens
then it goes to the other side again
okay does that mean it's not truth no it
is truth so the design of the message to
the Lans was to rid the Church of just
such fanatical influences but it
actually did the opposite yeah because
doesn't apply to me that means
self-righteousness right yeah if you
take the testimony and you want to apply
to everybody else you're going to have
the same problem that that they you have
to apply to you but the effort of Satan
has been to corrupt the message and
Destroy its influence he would be better
pleased to have fanatical persons
embrace the testimony and use it in his
course than to have them remain in a
lukewarm state so he wants Bashers yeah
do we have Bashers in the church
unfortunately we do okay and do we have
people that say my way or the highway
yes if you don't do it exactly like I
think should be
done then you have no right in this
organization but there's a little bit of
a Twist because of not a Twist a problem
because there's
testimonies that they use to justify why
they're saying it okay but they misapply
it because the testimony is also
applicable to the person giving it the
testimonies was never given to a person
to go imp implement it on somebody else
no it's just a testimony it's a
testimony from God as to the state of
the church and to you yes us because you
are part of the church da of the church
I've seen that it was not the design of
the message to lead brother to sit in
judgment over his brother to tell him
what to do and just how far to go for
but for each individual to search his
own heart and attend to his own
individual work it is the work of the
angels to watch the development of
character and we moral worth this is the
message to the lorded Sans so this is
how we should approach this whole
message and through this that we can
also touch on Unity because can you get
Unity as we are supposed to like um
Jesus prayed if one group thinks you are
fanatical and the other one group thinks
you totally off the course liberal
there's no Unity there cannot be a Unity
so if we look at
Romans where it says in honor preferring
one another then there is to be no
unkind criticism no pulling to pieces of
another's work and there are to be no
separate
parties every man to whom the Lord has
entrusted a message has his specific
work each one has an individuality of
his own which he is not to sink into
that of any other man yet each is to
work in harmony with his brethren in
their service God's workers are to be
essentially one no one is to set himself
up as a Criterion speaking
disrespectfully of his fellow workers or
Tre treating them as
inferior Martin if this Spirit doesn't
exist in the church I get so many
messages from people that say they want
to leave the church MH mhm and this is
what they use
exactly and some of them if they want to
do what is right they feel that they are
the targets
M and this is the church
militant it's going to have those two
parties in it and only those on whom the
Lan message has actually worked yes oh
wow will be part of the final Remnant
that that is unfortunately how it is
that's the criteria and I don't know
who's to be no me and you all of us
that's why we like you said we not they
yes have to take the ludian message and
apply it to my own yes we have to think
about it in terms of ourselves not in
terms of the others that's it and then
work with your BS leave the rest to God
all right now if you you think that
you've studied this through and you've
decided you know you're going to do this
right and you're going to be perfect
and you're going to strive for the
[Music]
sinlessness then eventually Pride can
come in and you can say well this is
achievable and the fact of the matter is
it
is but you may not have the element of
Pride attached to it because then you
become
judgmental right you have who else who
who show how this is done except Jesus
yes nobody so the clim CLA to be sinless
Martin this is such an important
one there's a wonderwork power to appear
and it will be when men are claiming
sanctification and Holiness lifting
themselves up higher and higher and
boasting of themselves can you see the
pride element oh for sure that's look at
Moses and the prophets look at Daniel
and Joseph and Elijah look at these men
and find me one sentence where they ever
claim to be
sinless the very soul that is in close
relation to Christ beholding his Purity
and Excellence see will fall before him
with
shamefacedness so I will never be
inclined to say I'm sinless I'm holy let
God write it in his book if he wants to
he can do it he can decide that but not
me I must also classify myself like
Daniel with the we have sinned we have
sinned none of us are perfect so here
again pride comes into the issue so when
we look at Daniel who had great skill he
did not say Lord I've been very faithful
to you and I've done everything to honor
you and defend your word and name did he
do those things no not at all oh did do
it in his life yes yes he did it in his
life but he never said it never said it
yeah Lord you know how faithful I was at
the king's table and how I maintained my
Integrity when they they cast me into
the Den of Lions was that the way Daniel
prayed to God
no he prayed and confessed his sins and
said here oh Lord and deliver and we
have departed from Thy word and have
sinned but ladia seems to say yes but
you know we're a special generation yes
we're not like them we we're going to
achieve something higher than they did
no there's going to be a new way of
Salvation can't cannot because God never
changed
and exactly let's put it bluntly the
144,000 will not be in the end any
different from what Adam and Eve had to
attain because God's Jesus's
righteousness will be over them yes and
even Joshua the high priest in that that
uh story of Jesus facing
Satan said uh remove his filthy robes
and put a fair miter on his head so this
is our state whether we like it or
whether we don't like it and as it says
over here you know Jesus had to come to
him in the appearance of a man he would
not have been able to stand in the
presence of God so why is it that so
many claim to be holy and sinless it is
because they are so far from
Christ I've never dared to claim any
such thing from the the time I was 14
years old if I knew what the will of God
was I was willing to do it you never
have heard me say I'm sinless those that
get a sight of the loveliness and
exalted character of Jesus Christ who
was holy and lifted up and his train
fills the temple will never say it yet
we are to meet with those that will say
such things more and
more we have so many forums that seem to
push this
angle constant ly if they were concerned
about saving
Souls out
there and partaking in the work that the
Lord has given them they would be
examples for people to follow you see
the more you study the spirit of
Prophecy along with the Bible the more
you realize when you are busy with the
work the other things will start sorting
itself out but when you're focused only
on those things
then that's where you end up with yes
and your focus is within that's it
that's immediately where the problem
Lies when your focus is in within so we
need to be refined cleansed from all
earthliness till we reflect the image of
our savior and become partakers of the
divine nature having escaped the
corruption that is in the world through
lust this you have to do yeah but once
you say I've done it you've lost it
you've lost it and once you want to bash
everybody else to do this you've got the
same problem Jesus has to do that work
that's the holy spirit's Holy Spirit but
we shall not boast of our Holiness we
cannot say I'm sinless till this vile
body is changed in Fashions like unto
his glorious body but if we constantly
seek to follow Jesus the Blessed Hope Is
Ours of standing Before the Throne of
God without spot or wrinkle or any such
thing completing Christ robed in
righteousness and Perfection so M have
you been changed into his glorious body
no not yet not yet so M are you can you
say you are
sinless no I'm blind and wretched and
naked does that mean that you have to
carry on sinning
no how do you get that
across you walk after right behind Jesus
and you don't you're not a judge so
Martin can we say that Jesus is walking
in front of us
MH he's walking in the middle of the
path where Justice and mercy meet yeah
isn't that where we should walk exactly
the same place we are to follow exactly
behind him not wavering to the left
where we Proclaim that his love covers
all but we neglect the necessity to obey
that's the one extreme neither should we
waver to the right from behind him where
we stand as a police Poli men to
constantly correct our brothers and
sisters and in both cases we might seem
to still be following but we are of the
path so is that the message to the LED
sins that is the message it's an
individual message to you to me me is it
the message of the righteousness of
Christ yes all right whose righteousness
Christ's righteousness are you sure yes
nobody else not mine so let's say that
you received the righteousness of Christ
whose have you
received the his his yeah he there's no
all right so where does that give you
the right to say that you are
righteous none zero there's no you don't
have any right to do that
okay that's very discouraging no it's
actually encouraging because then you
don't have to be discouraged when you
don't it can't do it okay PS said 9:14
Justice and judgment are the habitation
of thy Throne mercy and Truth Shall go
before thy face when we study the Divine
character in the light of the Cross we
see Mercy tenderness forgiveness
blending with equity and
Justice do we see condemnation
harshness any one of those attributes
none
so do we see an
intolerance to the failures of others
yes yes we do that's what we see right
yes we are constantly intolerant all
right mustn't we encourage people rather
than condemn bringing with love the
truth what did Jesus say neither do I
condemn you did he condemn the sin
yes ah for
sure ah he condemned the sin not the
person we see in the midst of the throne
one bearing in his hands and feets
inside the marks of the suffering
endured to reconcile man to God we see a
father infinite dwelling in light
unapproachable yet receiving us to
himself through the merits of his son
The Cloud of Vengeance that threatened
only misery and despair in the light
reflected from the cross reveals the
writings of God live sinner live ye
penitent believing Souls live I have
paid a ransom so Martin the only
boasting that we have is boasting in
Christ yes the only boasting that we
have is that Christ has done all for me
and at least I can claim that for myself
so I can count all the rest is rubbish
yes is that what Paul said yeah so mercy
and Truth are met together righteousness
and peace have kissed each other while
you seek to administer
Justice remember that she has a twin
sister which is Mercy isn't this a
beautiful statement it's
amazing because why we always separate
them yeah we always forget it we we just
walk with one sister okay so we have
Justice on the one side and mercy on the
other side that's it the two stand side
by side side and should not be
separated so I think our picture here is
actually quite to the point we cannot go
through the gate if we don't follow
right behind
Jesus so with that verse in mind or that
statement in mind I think we can
conclude the litan message it's a
personal
message it's a message which lays the
emphasis on the righteousness of
Christ it's an emphy which lays self
into the dust it is a a message of
following and not running
ahead and it's a message of not
deviating from the footsteps that went
before you amen amen we should make it
personal and then get that same attitude
and the love that Christ has for people
in he never walked around condemning and
when we accept it we can become part of
that Remnant that will bring the loud
cry amen and we have to talk about that
also in the future let's
pray Heavenly Father the message to the
Lans is not one that sits well with
Humanity it goes against the Fallen
nature it puts our existence Our Lives
into perspective
accepting the litan
message is not conducive to man's plans
of being somebody and
something but in Heaven's plan it makes
them something and
someone so help us Lord to do that
introspection study Our Lives see if we
are in harmony with the word and ask God
to change us into his similitude in in
Jesus name amen amen
[Music]